[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
Willkommen an diesem ersten Januar 2023
Norbert König ist auch dabei für den
Sport guten Abend gutes Neues und das
sind die Nachrichten Themen von heute
Silvester nach der Pandemie wieder mit
mehr Feuerwerk aber auch mit
außergewöhnlich vielen Angriffen auf
Rettungskräfte Polizei und Feuerwehr
reisen ohne Grenzkontrollen Kroatien ist
seit heute Teil der schengenzone und hat
jetzt offiziell den Euro als Währung
und Dämpfer beim Neujahrsspringen der
deutsche Hoffnungsträger Karl Geiger
landet in garmisch-
erstmals seit zwei Jahren konnte an
diesem Silvester wieder fast
uneingeschränkt geböllert werden viele
nutzten das zum Teil mit tragischen
Folgen in Leipzig starb ein 17-Jähriger
in Sachsen-Anhalt sprengte sich ein Mann
die Hand weg auch gab es gezielte
Angriffe auf Sicherheitskräfte als
Reaktion fordern Polizeigewerkschafter
ein weitgehendes böllerverbot über Licht
und Schatten der Silvesternacht
berichtet Sven riden
Mitternacht an den Hamburger
Landungsbrücken die schiffshorner läuten
2023 ein und die Hansestadt feiert
wieder nach den ruhigen jahreswechseln
ist auch an der Elbe fast so etwas wie
ein früher gefühlt zu spüren
[Musik]
nur nett bin richtig richtig
mancherorts schlug die Stimmung
allerdings um eine Szene aus Berlin die
das hemmungslose Silvester zeigt ein
Mann wirft einen Feuerlöscher auf den
Rettungswagen die Scheibe hält der Stall
Flasche stand die Polizei kann den
Werfer festnehmen in vielen Großstädten
flog Feuerwerk gezielt in Richtung und
auf Polizei und Feuerwehr Berlin
stoppten 25 vermummte einen Einsatzwagen
und raubten ihn aus also eigentlich
macht mich sprachlos das sowas möglich
ist
25 vermummte auf dem Feuerwehrfahrzeug
neue Qualität
verstörende Bilder die mit feiern nichts
zu tun haben solche Szenen in Berliner
Straßenzügen vor allem die Polizei
musste einschreiten mehr als 100
Festnahmen unter teils
lebensgefährlichen Bedingungen
Feuerwerkskörper als Waffe gegen Autos
und Menschen sicherheits-
ehrlich an dieser Stelle
das ist fast nicht mehr zu glauben
da gibt es einiges aufzuarbeiten und
auch zu räumen in Hamburg kamen die
Kehrmaschinen schon kurz nach
Mitternacht 10 Tonnen Feier Silvester
Müll sind es alleine in der Hansestadt
der Jahreswechsel hinterlässt Spuren die
die sich beseitigen lassen und die über
die man noch reden wird
das neue bringt einiges an neuen Regeln
ab heute treten wichtige Änderungen in
Kraft zum Beispiel kommt das neue
Bürgergeld es löst die Hartz IV
Grundsicherung ab der Regelsatz für
Alleinstehende steigt damit auf 5002
Euro erhöht wird auch das Wohngeld und
zwar um durchschnittlich 190 auf 370
Euro monatlich außerdem sind jetzt mehr
als doppelt so viele Menschen
antragsberechtigt und auch das
Kindergeld steigt auf 250 Euro pro Monat
für jedes Kind
das sind aber nur einige der Neuerungen
was sich 2023 sonst noch ändert das
wichtigste haben wir für sie erklärt und
zusammengefasst auf ZDF heute und in
unserer App
mit dem Jahreswechsel übernimmt
Deutschland auch eine wichtige
militärische Aufgabe die Führung der
schnellen Eingreiftruppe der NATO 8000
Bundeswehrsoldaten stünden im Ernstfall
an vorderster Front sie müssen innerhalb
von höchstens 72 Stunden bereit sein in
ihr Einsatzgebiet geschickt zu werden
die schnelle Eingreiftruppe wurde 2014
nach der Annexion der Krim durch
Russland gegründet derzeit beteiligen
sich insgesamt neuen NATO-Staaten
wird es Neujahr der Ukraine Frieden
bringen das wünschen sich so viele auch
der ukrainische Präsident doch bislang
ist ein schnelles Ende dieses Krieges
nicht in Sicht das machten sowohl
silensky als auch krämische Putin in
ihren Neujahrsansprachen deutlich
Russland setzt seine Angriffe fort auch
zum Jahreswechsel über ein Silvester im
Krieg berichtet eine Brühl
Ruhm der Ukraine rufen die Menschen in
Kiew sich um Mitternacht zu alle sind in
ihren Wohnungen es ist Ausgangssperre
35 Minuten später greifen die Russen die
Region mit insgesamt 30 Drohnen an
Explosionen Chaos Luftalarm
die Neujahrsansprache des Präsidenten
klingt entschlossen
[Musik]
ich wünsche uns allen eins den Sieg das
ist die Hauptsache ein Wunsch für alle
Ukrainer lass dieses Jahr das Jahr der
Rückkehr werden
an diesem milden Neujahrstag drängt es
auch in Kiew die Menschen nach draußen
viele schauen sich die Schäden der
russischen Angriffe der vergangenen 24
Stunden an
das neue Jahr beginnt hier wie das alte
geendet hat mit russischem Terror gegen
die Zivilbevölkerung vier Stunden
Luftangriffe in der Nacht Stunden die
die Menschen in ihren Wohnungen
ausharren mussten nur die wenigsten
haben Zugang zu Luftschutzkellern
und trotzdem wollen viele auch nach
vorne schauen erzählen uns von Ihren
Wünschen fürs neue Jahr
natürlich Frieden einen friedlichen
Himmel und den Sieg
Frieden und Waffen erstmal Waffen und
dann kommen fliegen
das beliebteste Fotomotiv hier fest der
Weihnachtsbaum der Unbesiegbarkeit
geschmückt ist der mit Friedenstauben
[Musik]
die Zerstörungen in der Ukraine seien
unerträglich sagte der Papst zum
Weltfriedenstag heute wenn das Jahr gut
werden solle dann gehe das nur mit
Fürsorge und Liebe sagt franziskus alle
müssten sich kümmern um das eigene Leben
die eigene Zeit und Seele um die Umwelt
und mehr noch um den nächsten bei der
traditionellen Neujahrsmesse betete
franziskus auch für den gestern
Verstorbenen Benedikt den 16 der Vatikan
veröffentlichte Bilder vom Leichnam des
emeritierten Papstes morgen wird er
öffentlich im Petersdom aufgebaut dort
können Gläubige bis Mittwoch Abschied
nehmen
Nordkoreas Machthaber Kim Jong-un will
dass Atomwaffenarsenal des Landes
drastisch aufstocken Kim kündigte den
baut taktischer und strategischer
Sprengköpfe an das Land wurde auch
weitere Interkontinentalraketen
herstellen er begründete den Schritt mit
angeblichen Angriffsplänen Südkoreas und
der USA zuvor hatte das Militär erneut
eine ballistische Rakete in Richtung
offenes Meer abgefeuert die vierte
innerhalb von 24 Stunden
für Kroaten und Kroatien Urlauber bringt
der erste Januar gleich zwei erfreuliche
Änderungen offizielles Zahlungsmittel
ist ab sofort der Euro und das Reisen
wird einfacher das EU-Mitglied an der
Adria ist dem sogenannten Schengenraum
beigetreten heißt vorbei die Zeiten von
aufwendigen Grenzkontrollen und langem
Warten Britta Hilpert berichtet
ein Grenzübergang in Partystimmung das
gab zum Mitternacht in Kroatien in
plauvania feiern Sie das neue Jahr und
die freie Durchfahrt an der Grenze seit
heute ist das jüngste EU-Land auch
Mitglied im Schengen Raum und der Euro
ist offizielles Zahlungsmittel
ist der Takko kroatien wird damit noch
mehr zusammenwachsen mit dem Kreis der
am stärksten entwickelten Länder der
Welt
Kroatien hängt wirtschaftlich ab vom
Tourismus der Euro befördert den meinen
auch die Wintergäste natürlich jetzt für
uns einfacher als deutsche
überall wo wir hinfahren ist das Euro
Nachteil wird wahrscheinlich nicht daran
sein dass eben die koraten
jetzt ein bisschen teurer wird es
steigen die Preise schon länger über 13
Prozent Inflation hat Kroatien auch sei
das Wirtschaftswachstum zu schwach und
jetzt den Euro einzuführen meint
Ex-Finanzminister und
wirtschaftsprofessorchic mit unserer
Wirtschaftsstruktur dem
Entwicklungsstand und der Wachstumsrate
wird der Euro jetzt nur negative Folgen
haben
die Preise sind schon länger auch in
Euro ausgezeichnet die Mehrheit der
Kroaten ist eher für den Euro nur manche
befürchten versteckte Preiserhöhung ich
hätte den Kuna lieber behalten
er macht es leichter für uns im
Tourismus
der Euro muss sich bei den Kroaten noch
bewähren eu-reisen ohne grenzstopp wird
dagegen von allen begrüßt
in Brasilien beginnt das Jahr mit einem
Machtwechsel von einem sehr Rechten zu
einem sehr linken Präsidenten es ist ein
alter Bekannter den die Anhänger dazu
jubeln der Sozialist Lula da Silva wird
heute zum dritten Mal vereidigt von 2003
bis 2011 war er bereits im Amt wegen
Drohungen von
oppositionsanhängern gelten strenge
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen Christoph
röckerath
zu Tausenden strömen sie in die
Hauptstadt Brasilien die Anhänger von
Louis inazio Lula das Silva dem nächsten
Präsidenten Brasiliens wollen dabei sein
wenn er den Eid ablegt und das Land
offiziell die Zeit seines extrem rechten
Vorgängers jayboard zur naro hinter sich
lässt
okay
wir sind befreit vom bolzenarismus was
wir in diesen vier Jahren durchgemacht
haben ist unbeschreiblich deshalb
erfüllt mich heute die Fröhlichkeit
ich bin hier für die Hoffnung die Liebe
für ein besseres Leben um die vier Jahre
des Rückschritts zu beenden die
Brasilien erlebt hat dass wir nun
Wohlstand haben das ist ein gutes neues
Jahr wird Brasilien ist Lula und war es
schon immer das ist die Sicht seiner
Anhänger doch in Wahrheit übernimmt der
links gerichtete Lula ein tief
gespaltenes Land das Wahlergebnis war
knapp viele Anhänger des abgewählten
Präsidenten bolzenaru akzeptieren die
neue Realität nicht und fordern vor
Kasernen ein Militärputsch einige
schrecken auch vor Gewalt nicht zurück
vor wenigen Tagen will die Polizei sogar
ein Bombenattentat in der Hauptstadt
verhindert haben
Wahl Verlierer wollte sonaro dagegen hat
das Land längst den USA verlassen
persönlich will er die Macht nicht
übergeben
Lule hat nichts Geringeres als eine
Zeitenwende versprochen vor allem was
soziales und den Umweltschutz angeht und
so soll die Ernennung der ersten indigen
Ministerin mehr sein als nur ein Symbol
demonstrativ reicht auch das Ausland
Brasilien wieder die Hand
Bundespräsident Steinmeier macht den
Anfang ein möglicher Neustart in den
Beziehungen zwischen Brasilien und
Europa
jetzt Sport Vierschanzentournee da
schwinden die Hoffnungen auf einen
deutschen Gesamtsieg ja ist so mit Platz
acht Wellinger oder 11 Geiger macht man
eben keine großen Sprünge nach vorn ganz
anders der Norweger hallwurfner granery
heute in Garmisch-Partenkirchen zweiter
Wettkampf zweiter Sieg der 26-Jährige
hat schon umgerechnet 32 Meter Vorsprung
auf Karl Geiger und ist die Ruhe selbst
er wirkt wie ein stiller Genießer
halberegner grande rüt bleibt der große
Überflieger dieser Tournee nach seinem
Triumph beim Auftakt springen in
Oberstdorf springt der Norweger heute am
Neujahrstag mit 140 und 142 Metern in
beiden durchgängern Bestweite und siegt
überlegen vor dem Slowenen an celanische
und dem Polen David Kubatzki KRONEHIT
Freunde und die Eltern sind zu Tränen
gerührt den Final Durchgang in
Garmisch-Partenkirchen erreichen
insgesamt sieben deutsche Skispringer
Geiger wird heute nur Elfter und fällt
in der Gesamtwertung auf Frankfurt
zurück zur Elfter Platz es ist Glaube
alles im Rahmen die ganz vorne setzen
sich natürlich schon mal so fair und
sportlich muss man sein dass man das das
zu würdigen weiß dass man da noch nicht
ganz Mitmenschen kann bester Deutscher
heute beim Neujahrsspringen ist Andreas
Wellinger als 18 er bleibt auf Platz
sechs der Gesamtwertung
mit dem ersten Weltcup Podestplatz ihrer
Karriere beschließt Selina Freitag die
Silvestertour der Skispringerinnen in
Loop 9 Slowenien ein Flug im zweiten
Durchgang auf 122 Meter mit guter
Landung beschert ihr Rang drei und Platz
4 in der Gesamtwertung vor Katharina
Althaus
herausragende tournesiegerin die
Österreicherin Eva pink mit dem dritten
Sieg im vierten springen
und bei der Langlauf Tour de Ski hat
Olympiasiegerin Katharina Hennig im
zweiten von sieben Rennen einen großen
Schritt nach vorne getan in der 10 km
Verfolgung von walnüsseier stürmt sie
von Startplatz 21 noch auf Rang 6 diese
Position belegt sie auch insgesamt 42
Sekunden hinter der tages-siegerin
schöner Name finde ich auch haben nicht
lang gefeiert wahrscheinlich Dankeschön
Norbert zum Schluss noch mal zu den
farbenfrohen Seiten des Jahreswechsels
weltweit wurde mit Feuerwerk und Böllern
gefeiert wie hier an der Copacabana in
Rio de Janeiro auf dem New Yorker Time
Square
jubelten zehntausende als Punkt
Mitternacht die berühmte Kristallkugel
abwärts schwebte
in London gab es das gigantische
Feuerwerk am London Eye und am Vormittag
die traditionelle neujahrsparade durch
die Straßen übrigens die größte der Welt
das Wetter wird morgen so in der
nordwest-hälfte zeitweise Regen sonst
meistfreundlich teils mit längerem
Sonnenschein bei lebhaften und im
Bergland stürmischem Südwestwind 9 bis
17 Grad und die weiteren Aussichten
unbeständig und wieder kühler um 23 Uhr
bringt Sie Christina von Ungarn
Sternberg auf den neuesten
nachrichtenstand wir sagen tschüss
wünschen Ihnen einen guten Start in die
erste Woche dieses Jahres und sind
morgen wieder da auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]